frente al monumento conmemorativo del
World Trade Center en Nueva York la
emoción sigue siendo muy fuerte 21 años
hasta el día de hoy después de los
atentados como en cada ceremonia el
mismo ritual el himno nacional
estadounidense seguido de un minuto de
silencio
[Música]
los nombres de las víctimas son
pronunciados por los familiares de los
fallecidos cerca de 3000 personas
murieron en los atentados perpetrados
por al caída el 11 de septiembre de 2001
la vicepresidenta kamalaharis y su
marido están presentes pero aquí en la
Zona cero no hablará ningún líder
político como ya es tradición
era la mejor persona que he conocido el
mejor marido un hombre bueno y
trabajador por eso vengo aquí cada año y
sostengo su retrato los desconocidos
pueden verlo y recordar su cara
en el estado vecino de Virginia yo
bailon fue el pentágono donde un avión
se estrelló contra la sede del
departamento de defensa puso una corona
de flores y emitió un discurso de unidad
nacional a unos meses de las elecciones
de medio término
la determinación del pueblo
estadounidense de defenderse de quienes
lo quieren matar y hacer justicia por
las víctimas de estos ataques contra
nuestros ciudadanos siguen siendo un
éxito se necesitaron 10 años para
encontrar y matar a Bin Laden pero lo
hicimos he autorizado un ataque contra
aimana el sawajiri el hombre que estaba
al lado del jefe de al qaeda Durante los
atentados no nos rendiremos no
olvidaremos nunca y no abandonaremos
nunca
en la ceremonia de este año es también
la ocasión de recordar la amistad entre
Estados Unidos y la Reina Isabel II tres
días después de su fallecimiento
[Música]
recuerdo un mensaje que la Reina Isabel
envió al pueblo estadounidense fue el 11
de septiembre
muchos han experimentado esta pena todos
ustedes lo han hecho
y en este día cuando revivimos este
dolor Jelly y yo pensamos mucho en usted
dos días después de los atentados la
reina ordenó a los guardias de
colestream tocar por primera y única vez
en la historia de Reino Unido el himno
de Estados Unidos
[Música]